how did you get involved with Young
Turks oh well um I had a kite and hours
Comedy Central special called citizen
Jimmy which is chosen best of the Year
by iTunes thank you very much and the
reason why I tell you that because if I
don't nobody will
so uh they saw it somebody who worked
there saw it and when jenk got his job
at MSNBC he was a host on MSNBC they
needed guest hosts and so they called me
in and they said hey you're a political
comedian you had a political comedy
special would you like to host well I
was ready right because I had been doing
my live Jimmy at door show at or it was
called pop and politics back then at the
UCB theater in Hollywood and so I was
doing video work and I knew how I had a
you know as I was ready so when they
opened the door I could walk through and
they told me they said I remember they
never forget they said don't read the
comments because everybody's gonna hate
you they only like Jank and
what I did the show everybody liked me
and they're like this is amazing you
should go and that's when they made me a
regular host and the rest is history did
you ever ask them why they named the
organization after the genocidal Young
Turks from The Armenian Genocide that
basically created their Armenian
like why uh I did ask them they said
they were going to call it the young
pedophiles
no the way what I was told was is which
which is the public story that it means
that you're a young like a Turk meaning
a an uh a rebel a young upstarter that
literally is a reference and he happens
to be from turkey and then he did deny
the genocide for a while he doesn't
anymore but that so that's why that
didn't look I'm sure they're very
excited we're talking about this so it
gives them an opportunity to make shock
content for Their audience I'm all about
like retribution and like making the
swastika great again you know the wheel
of life that the Nazis ripped off but
like calling it The Young Turks when
they created The Armenian I don't
understand that chank like here's here's
what I think with The Young Turks I
think that they
you've got young people entering the
political sphere with no experience they
don't know who Obama is they don't know
who Joe Biden is and I mean that in the
uh not like they've obviously heard the
names yeah but they don't know what they
did and this this is a really great
example of this is when we had vosh on
the show I think you know vashas he said
when I when I asked him like didn't
don't you know about what Joe Biden did
when he was in the Obama Administration
I mean from 08 until 16 he goes I was in
high school I don't even know anything
about that
I don't blame him this is this is how
the Democrats operate they target young
people who aren't old enough to know
that their psych they're psychotic and
evil and then say we should lower the
voting age to 16. so for The Young Turks
what I think happens is
they've got a new younger audience
they're more woke they're more leftist
they're very tribal and if they go the
honest route they're right-wing
conservatives now but there is a faction
of liberals who are tribal and have
always been and are probably aging with
them so they're I I have to imagine
there's a point where junk euger was
sitting in his chair Sweating Bullets
thinking to himself this story is not
true but if I don't say it we're going
to lose all of our members I have no
choice but to say it and then he does
and that becomes his thing and I have to
imagine it's psychological torture but
he's trapped in that world now I think
that's why he's become so angry and so
like ah and screaming and yelling
because he knows he has to lie to people
there's no way a person who runs a
business like he does who reads the news
like he does is is unaware that he's
lying because if you take 10 seconds
I'll give you the example Donald Trump
called White Supreme white surprises
verifying people never happened I
remember I was watching that press
conference and he said they should be
condemns totally and I was like well how
about that and then the next day all of
a sudden they're like Trump called White
supremacists very fine people and I was
like what no he didn't
someone like Jack euger Anna kasparian
if they come out and tell people the
truth like you mentioned with Paul
manafort they're going to lose money a
lot of it they're going to get attacked
they're going to lose street cred so
they opt for I'm just gonna say what the
audience wants to hear someone like me
at the time I said I'll tell you what's
true it ends up working out for me in
the long run I think for you as well
right now you've got crossover between
people on the left and the right who are
like Jimmy's an honest guy they I either
agree with his opinions or I don't but
those people are liars this guy's honest
that's right so I think people are
starved for honesty and so there's a lot
of right Wingers
or people who consider themselves
conservatives uh who find my show and
they're like hey I like this guy I don't
agree with them this but I like that I
don't understand and that's how it's
supposed to work Tim you know that right
politics is all about finding common
ground politics is all about uh
convincing people to come to your point
of view through the strength of your
arguments that's what politics is all
about and they try to so they try to uh
discredit me The Young Turks by calling
saying I have a right-wing audience
which I I'd say it's pretty mixed
audience but what they go half his
audience is right wing which means half
of it isn't which that's a good thing
which means I have broad appeal and
that's they're supposed to make that's
not bad that's what you're supposed to
be going for they're they're bragging
about having no conservative viewers
they say they are and so how are you
going to turn anybody so I get comments
all the time also that I used to think
this about that and now I don't because
of Jimmy I used to think this but that
but now watching him I think this and so
I've turned people's opinions on things
which is what you're supposed to do
which is what I want to do with this
show right I've got a lot of messages
from people saying that I've convinced
them to oppose the death penalty because
oh B2 I did it to jenk on air
so that's my get him to support it or
oppose it my proudest moment I swear to
God one of mine if you could look it up
it's still on YouTube
um we're doing some panel and we're
talking about the death penalty and I
just very calmly I started to question
him about why you for the death penalty
and why it's wrong and and he was all
about uh it's okay if they get it right
but if they get it wrong then it's bad
so he's against it because they get it
wrong and I had to tell him no just the
idea is wrong that violence doesn't
solve violence violence creates more
violence and why do you think when they
do it they didn't do it in Town Square
they do it behind curtains because we're
not Pro I'm sorry
yeah they used to do it publicly yeah
and but they stopped right and so Phil
Donahue another guy used to advocate for
doing executions in public and they made
him think he was crazy and the reason
why he said that was because we want to
see what we're doing you want to see
what we're actually doing let's take a
look at it and let's deal with it and
then either we keep doing it or we don't
but let's challenge our yourself let's
not do it in the dark let's not have
Justice that's not how you serve Justice
in the dark behind a curtain let's talk
about what it even means to be left and
right this is funny there's a there's a
meme uh it's sad
our Twitter post that went viral people
screenshot it if you were on the left
and they describe you as a lefty and you
deviate on leftist economic policy I
don't care that's fine okay whatever if
you deviate in terms of woke Ideology
Now You're a right winger
it's funny though because thinking about
that if you're on the right and you lie
you're a liar if or I should say this if
you lie online conservatives will call
you a liar if you are on the internet
and you are conservative they will call
you a conservative if you are on the
internet and you're a leftist they will
call you a leftist if you deviate from
those opinions they'll say hey your
opinion changed
on the left they'll just say you're
right wing you're right wing your right
wing unless you agree with with us on
the tribal ideological issue but if you
you could claim to be pro-blm you could
claim to be you know uh in support of
trans kids and all that stuff but
question Universal Health Care and they
have no problem with that
so I interviewed I don't know if you
know but a big watershed moment at my
show was I interviewed a Boogaloo boy
and now people don't know anything about
the Boogaloo boy either did I that's why
I interviewed him
and what I found out was exactly what
you just said so this Boogaloo Boy comes
on my show and he tells people that the
Boogaloo boys were invented as a
response to the proud boys they're not
pro so people would conflate Boogaloo
boys and proud boys because the media
lies and that's right and so the
Boogaloo boys were actually people who
were seeking Common Ground they were
pro-black lives matter they were
anti-war they were anti-cop
um they shake hands with antifa invite a
bunch of videos and they yes they March
together they marched with that so
that's the video I saw of this guy
Magnus and he had a black lives matter
person with him he had a gay person with
him and then it was him and he's a
Libertarian and he said we see Common
Ground we're not your enemy our enemy
and I was like this let's bring this guy
on I found out he was pro-gay Pro they
provided security for uh the black lives
matter protests so their Pro black life
matter pro-lgbtq uh their anti-war
anti-cop what else do you guys this this
that's five four or five out of the top
10 issues I have we can agree on we
could work on they demonize me like you
can't do that that guy's this he's that
and I'm like so I had literally I had a
guy come on after I interviewed him from
the world socialist website
and he's supposed to be a union
organizer his name is Jerry something
and I can't remember his last name and
you never heard of it anyway because
this guy's never accomplished a goddamn
thing in his life and he came on and he
started to rip me for interviewing that
guy and I go Jerry what's your message
to that guy this guy's being affected by
the economic crushing from kova just
like everybody else what's your message
don't you have a message to recruit him
because if you don't have a message the
Nazis are going to have a message we got
to have a message he goes I don't have a
message for that guy and I'm like well
that's why nobody ever heard of you and
that's why you've never accomplished
anything in your life because that's not
how you organize you know how you
organize just like Christian Smalls did
at the Amazon warehouse on Staten Island
now if you don't know of Staten Island
it's all full of trump voters and he's a
black guy who organized a union of trump
voters on Staten Island and how do you
do that well I'll tell you how you don't
do it you don't go to the union floor go
who cares a proud boy you're out who's a
boogly boy you're out who doesn't like
Social Security you're out who's against
lgbtq you're out who's who's a
Libertarian gun nut you're out okay
who's left now let's organize that's not
how you do it everybody knows that's not
how you organize the way when you when
people on the left say we're going to
organize along class lines they don't
even realize what they're saying because
what that means is organizing what
trumpers and they say we'll never do
that well that's what organizing along
class lines means and that's why
you haven't accomplished anything in
your life except divide the country your
neighbors not your enemy The
military-industrial Complex is your
enemy Wall Street is your enemy big
Pharma big insurance that is your enemy
not your neighbor thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time